in this series on the project on the
strip away only the complexity and hard
graft and teach you how to pick amazing
food standing on your head
there is amazing incredibly tender from
the kitchen novice to the budding chef
only give you the confidence that
recipes and the insider knowledge to
make you a much better cook slice we're
out wasting nothing
[Music]
I made my name cooking in some of the
world's most demanding kitchens
[Music]
in my restaurants I expect perfection
every plate has to be worthy of a
Michelin star and every time you make
now I'm going to show you some simple
and accessible recipes or fantastic food
that you can easily cook at home and
crow I'll be holding you by the hand
just getting better and better and
better teaching you everything from
incredible stress-free dishes real fast
food and my ultimate feast recipes this
is the only cookery course you'll ever
need
welcome to my ultimate cookery course
with cooking tips information and 100
recipes to stay in your life on right
this is my optimum food on a budget as a
chef I know it's not what you spend on
ingredients but results on the plate
that count using cheap cuts and
leftovers and working them hard in the
kitchen gives you food in the budget
that tastes a million bucks and I'm
gonna show you how first up my flavor
pack lamb with fry bread whether I'm
cooking high-end dishes or rustic dishes
trust me it all has to be impressive so
this lamb dish proves they don't have to
spend a fortune to create delicious food
first off the panel this is a lamb steak
and it's cut just above the leg just
here cuz you see that delicious bone
running through the center and that's
full of marrow so that just gives the
lamb a nice added sweet flavor just take
your knife cut through each end this
stops the lamb steak from buckling so
therefore it cooks evenly and colors
beautifully salt and pepper lamb needs
quite a little help with the pepper so
if I generous with a pencil I just Pat
that down the pans just under smoke on
the outside now put the oil in get that
pan really nice and hot because this is
a cheap cut so I'm depending on the
color of the lamb steaks are really sort
of impart a lot of flavor noise you want
to hear you kind of hear that noise
don't drop the steak in put a little bit
of garlic in there not chop garlic
this whole close the garlic lightly
crushed don't even waste time peeling
them in tongs lift up a bit of fat
around the bag that's what the top of
the leg tilt the pan and let all that
fat render rendering is a chef's term
that means melting the fat it works
brilliantly when you're cooking a ribeye
as well
[Music]
now it looks like an expensive cut and
we got that nice even sear all over as
it's cooking just tilt the pan and bake
I'm basing the lamb steak just means
just sort of adding all that nice
scented garlic olive oil back into the
lamb useful the lamb out let the lamb
rest
[Music]
now for the perfect rustic crouton
so this breads quite firm couple of days
old to slice it straight down the center
dice it up put into a bowl season it
beautifully from there and add some milk
sounds strange adding milk to a crouton
but it just gives it that nice rich
creamy texture
and just let that milk sort of absorb
into the bread while that's soaking
unlike the dressing go back to that
initial garlic that was in the pan
beautiful and flip s the mortar and
chievous anchovies go bring you well
with lamb on there nice salty vinegary
flavor on a big kick some capers their
little baby cats very sweet now just
pound that to a nice paste the smell is
incredible next some Dijon mustard a
nice teaspoon and a half in open up red
wine vinegar 2 tablespoons and then our
extra virgin olive oil
now it's got that heat in there got a
nice roasted garlic a real hearty chunky
vinaigrette that sort of seeps into that
lamp some fresh parsley crunch up the
parsley delicious flavor
pass the in nice now get your pan hot
for the croutons olive oil in the pan
grab the croutons and squeeze all that
excess milk am not too hard
I don't them dry and in fire them and
the milk inside these croutons
give it a nice spongy creamy delicious
flavor that's the color I want nice now
take them out and lightly drain them but
it kitchen roll onto the board out I
plate them just take it's amazing
vinaigrette just spread it for those
croutons listen to them my little
boulders hitting the plate the lamb sit
down on next one on rest the croutons
on now use all those little bits and my
chef in Paris would kill me right now if
you saw me using those because they're
they ugly scraps that customers should
never say but but they're the best bits
croutons on and then just drop and sauce
and whiz little bits on the lamb and
there is a perfect way of taking a cheap
cut is the Premier League of dishes
stunning food doesn't have to be
complicated keeping it simple produces
amazing results and keeps cost down here
are three more great easy dishes that
don't cost the earth but tastes
absolutely incredible
starting with roasted mackerel with
garlic and paprika
[Music]
first make a spicy paste by crushing
garlic and a pestle and mortar along
with paprika sea salt and olive oil
spoon the paste onto Phillips of
mackerel a great inexpensive oily fish
that's really healthy and leave to
marinate
when ready to eat put the makkal finish
on a baking trace inside our season and
roast in a hot oven
next make a tanky potato salad for the
dressing mix Dijon mustard white wine
vinegar olive oil and saffron
and whisk until blended
bought new potatoes in salted water
drain and lightly crushed add sliced
spring onion and spoon in the
vinaigrette
[Applause]
to surf top the potato salad with the
roasted mackerel and drizzle with more
vinaigrette
[Music]
a healthy meal that makes the most of
cheap but delicious fish stunning
roasted mackerel with garlic and paprika
[Music]
my next brilliant budget dish is pork
and prawn balls in aromatic broth
[Music]
for the pork and pork balls in a bowl
add pork mince then add finely chopped
prawns diced ginger and chopped chives
[Music]
season
and roll into ping-pong sized balls
for the broth meat fresh stock and add
star anis oyster sauce soy sauce and
sliced ginger gently simmer fry the pork
and prawn balls in a pan until golden
then transfer to the bubbling broth
[Music]
I've handfuls of spinach then serve top
with finely sliced spring onions a
gorgeous healthy dish that uses great
valu ingredients with amazing results
pork and prawn balls in aromatic broth
ready to eat in under 20 minutes an
incredibly simple recipe that's perfect
for using up leftovers easy arancini
delicious golden rice balls
[Music]
first chop mozzarella into small cubes
then take handfuls of leftover risotto
add a cube of mozzarella and fold into a
ball around the cheese this dish is
perfect with leftover mushroom risotto
but it's great with any risotto for the
coating prep three bowls one with flour
one with bread crumbs and one with
beaten egg dip each errand teeny first
into the flour then the egg wash and
finally the bread crumbs then in a pan
heat the olive oil and fry the arancini
until golden brown
[Music]
drain and surf simply with lemon
[Music]
easy arancini a delicious tempting treat
is great for leftovers and cooks in
under ten minutes three quick and easy
recipes that give maximum flavor from
minimum cost fantastic dishes that
preview don't have to spend a fortune to
eat mazing food at home bus next five
more buy 100 tips
they'll make cooking the kitchen easier
first up a great cheap staple how to
cook the perfect rice basmati rice the
king of all Rice's light fluffy
delicious and I'm going to show you how
to cook it perfectly now start off with
400 grams of rice rice in spot-on so
what I'm gonna do now is just rinse off
the dust and start cold water always and
is rinse the rice that stops the rice we
becoming clumpy in the pan and allowed
it become really nice light and fluffy
once it's cooked rice into the pan now
to make a plain fluffy rice exciting
we're going to infuse it three cardamom
pods and just get the pots and just piss
them so it allows all that flavor to
come out cardamom pods and then star
anis now these are beautiful whole star
anis it makes it really nice and
fragrant salt and pepper lot easier to
season the rice now then is once it's
cooked you start to break up when you
season once it's cursed
now that's basically one part rise to
one and a half part water
six hundred mils always started off in
cold water cold water in
onto the gas lid on bring it up to the
ball as quick as possible and turn it
down and let it simmer for eight to ten
minutes and that's the secret behind
cooking great rice allow it to steam as
it's cooking do not lift that lid up
lid off it smells aromatic basically all
the waters absorbed the rice has doubled
in size and is nice and light and fluffy
take the star anis out the cardamom pods
the hole should have risen to the top
pods out take your fork fluff it through
basically just sort of starts to open
thing back up once you fought you
through becomes really nice and light
and fluffy and there that is perfectly
cooked rice always make the most of your
leftovers use last night's rice in stir
Fry's scrambled up with eggs or it's
simple to make a delicious fresh salad
remember a good cook wastes nothing a
great tip for stopping potatoes apples
and avocados from going brown wing cut
simply cover water and add a squeeze of
lemon the acidity stops the flesh from
oxidizing which is what causes the color
to change
herbs are great for adding flavor
without spending a fortune to keep them
at their best simply place them in a
glass of water and they'll stay fresh
for up to a week and if you've got extra
herbs left over save them waste by
making an amazing flavored oil place
wash and dried stems in a bottle cover
with warmed olive oil then seal and
leave to infuse great for salads pastas
and drizzling on veg this is my ultimate
cookery course 100 recipes to stake your
life on later I'll be showing you an
incredible spicy sausage rice that cost
next to nothing
porky delicious and incredibly robust
but first when you're cooking on a
budget you can still eat fantastic meats
just make sure you're getting the most
for your money next up my shopping guide
to bind the best hams
salami 's and sausages
these fine Italian meats are packed with
flavor and a little goes a long way and
nobody knows that better than Delhi
maestro Antonio sukumari boring Italy
and stop eating Italian food and I love
it I want to change it for 90 days as I
am be selling delicious cured meats in a
heart of London Soho for more than 35
years this is the best prosciutto they
come from Italy this is curing power
because it's Parma ham
divine people love it once the fat is
good because you make the meat sweet
this should be cut thin like this there
is more flavor you can eat with melon
with faith with pears with everything
any sweet fruit is good this one you
really enjoy when you start eating
you can stop wonderful this is called
brizola it's a hare cured beef come from
Lourdes Italy Valtellina
is so different from pork there's no fat
at all it should be no further wise it
is greasy it's good when it's very dry
and you slice it Tina you just eat it
like that
or you can eat with a bit of rocket I
will shave some parmesan on top I love
it
bit of lemon if you like olive oil it's
delicious this is called Foligno for me
is the best salami take the name of a
little place near parma and there's a is
country salami very nice is one of my
favorite because it's not too spicy just
meat flavor just salt and pepper I love
it I can resist when I take some meat
home I don't need nothing else
especially evening just meat with a
melon or feet or whatever few slices of
bread couple glasses of wine that's my
meal
nothing there you are big antonio's
right incredible Italian hams and salami
z' are fantastic and simple salads
sandwiches or even eaten by themselves
and you don't need much to make an
impression there's an amazing selection
of delicious meats from around the world
that are great to use in the kitchen
another simple meaty staple is perfect
for quick easy suppers with a difference
of exotic regional speciality sausages
that have such distinctive taste and are
a million miles from the Great British
banger here are four my favorites
there are definitely worth your money
chorizo from Spain these have an
incredibly deep red color are full of
smoky spice paprika and are great for
stuffing stews and play Ella's mer gays
from North Africa made from beef or
mutton these cooks super fast because of
the long and thin shape and can be used
in tagines or served with couscous
fennel sausages Italy made from pork and
packed with sweet aniseed flavor fennel
seeds these are perfect with pasta or as
a topping on a pizza
finally jerk sausages from Jamaica full
of blow your head off scotch bonnet
chilies
these are super spicy and great in tangu
casseroles or simply sauteed with onions
and garlic be adventurous with your
sausages learn about the different
flavors and he'll soon be using them to
add extra flavor with ease the dishes
that always pack a punch without costing
a fortune simple and cheap delicious
ingredients like sausages are great and
you don't need a lot of them to get
stunning dishes that taste incredible so
spend your money wisely and you can have
amazing midweek meals that don't cost
the earth my next recipe is all about
great flavors and it's as cheap and easy
to make as it is delicious
spicy sausage rice whatever you're
cooking the secret of making great food
is to ensure you lock in every last
ounce of flavor in that pan and this
spicy sausage rice does exactly that
[Music]
take the spicy sausages and piss that
skin because I want all that delicious
spicy sausage meat out of this casing
and you get more flavor from the sausage
when you take them out the casing
sausage is ready turn on the gas red
onion less acidic got a big white
Spanish onion and a lot more flavor some
tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
only because I want all that fat coming
out of sausages just to really help
flavor the onions onions in and the
owners go in first because you can never
rush cooking an onion it's really
important to sort of give them 5 6
minutes in the pan so you can really
start the camera Liza and now for my
pepper slice around wasting nothing
I want to see that sort of little core
those pips in the center no fine dice
pepper the rice is going to be cooking
for 20 minutes so I want the veg to sort
of have texture after it's cooked
peppers in with a garlic to nice clothes
just slap down off with the shell garlic
in now I'll turn up the gas get the pan
nice and hot because the minute that
fossil goes in everything cools down and
you'll end up boiling and the peppers
and the onions of the garlic so heat up
to maximum and I'll just make a well in
the center I mean now start stirring
quickly this is where you get so much
more bang for your buck out of sausages
because it's skins off and the real
flavor of that spicy tangy sausage he's
gonna come through what's great about
this recipe is that you can use any type
of sausage to get the flavor and the
heat you want I've gone for the spicy
Italian but it's just as good with no
gays or chorizo
a teaspoon Rika and give it that really
nice smoky flavor ricin and we're gonna
sort of basically sear the rice we call
it in the kitchen
blasting the rice where we sort of noted
that rice for 30 seconds and it takes on
all that flavor next white wine so the
wine sort of deglazing the pan and
watching all that flavor on the bottom
of the pan into the rice stock in bring
it up to the boil turn it down and let
it simmer double stop - rice turn that
gas down and let it simmer for 12 to 15
minutes and just give it the occasional
stir keep an island now get ready to
finish it sliced spring onions diced
sweet juicy tomatoes and roughly chopped
earthy flat leaf parsley
springers in tomatoes in off with the
gas really important otherwise
everything becomes overcooked flat leaf
parsley in but look at the volume in
that pan now that is an amazing way to
take spicy internal sausages to a
completely different level beautiful
[Music]
follow my ultimate cookery course packed
with key lessons top tips and 100
recipes to stake your life on and you'll
literally be cooking yourself into a
better chef many of these amazing
recipes are on my app please check out
the App Store for details go on get
cooking
you